in the last video we saw that if we have
two currents or two wires carrying
current and the current is going in the
same direction that they'll attract each
other now what would happen before we
break into the numbers what would happen
if the two currents are going in
opposite directions what would would
they attract or repel each other and you
could probably guess that but let's go
through the exercise just because i
realized the last time i did it i did it
i got a little bit messy and i'll do a
little bit cleaner this i don't have to
draw as many magnetic field lines
so let's say that's y one
that's wire two
that's my wire two and i'll make the
currents go go in opposite directions so
this is
i1
and this is i2 so what would the
magnetic field created by current one
look like well let's do our wrap around
rule put our thumb in the direction of
the current and then the magnetic field
will wrap around it'll go into the page
here
and it'll go out of the page here right
if you point your thumb up like that
your right hand always use your right
hand
and then you'll get that type of magnet
feel and of course it's going into the
page into the video screen all the way
out to infinity it gets weaker and
weaker
it's inversely proportional to the
radius away from the wire it'll get
weaker weaker but even here this
magnetic field is going
into the page
now we know just as a little bit of
review the force on this the force
on
the force created by
current one on current two that's just
the convention i'm using you wouldn't
always put the one first is equal to
current two
current two times some length let's call
that length 2 along the wire this is
going to be a vector because it's a
magnitude of length and a direction
and it goes in the same direction as
as
the current so that's let's say that
that is l2
right so we're talking about from here
to here
that's the current
cross product that with
the magnetic field i'll switch back to
that the magnetic field created by one
and always seems pretty complicated but
you can just take your right hand rule
and figure out figure out the direction
so we put our index finger i'm doing it
right now you can't see it you put your
index finger
in the direction let me see
you put your index finger there you go
in the direction of l2 you can write the
2 down here instead of writing a big 2
right there put your index finger in the
direction of l2
i keep redoing it just to make sure i'm
drawing it right
put your middle finger in the direction
of so this is l2 this is this
goes in the direction the middle finger
put your sorry the index finger your
middle finger is going to go in the
direction of the field so it's going to
be pointing downwards right because the
field is going into the page to the
right on this side of this wire
and your other hands are going to do
what they will
and then your thumb is going to go in
the direction of the net force so your
thumb is going to go like that
so there you have it this is the top of
your hand you have your little veins or
tendons whatever those are that's your
nail
that's your nail so in this situation
when the current is going in opposite
direction
the net force is actually going to be
outward on this wire the net force is
outward and then if you don't believe me
you could
you might want to try it yourself but
the the force on current one or on wire
one or some length of wire one
caused by the magnetic field due to
current two is also going to be outwards
so here if you want to you know think
about a little bit or have a little bit
of intuition if the current is going in
the same direction they will attract and
if the currents are going in opposite
directions they will repel each other
so anyway let's let's apply some numbers
all right let's apply some numbers to
this problem let's do it with the the
opposite current direction
so let's say that current 1 i'm just
going to make up some numbers is 2
amperes
current 2
is
i don't know
three amperes
what else do we know we need another how
how far apart they are so let's say that
this distance
right here
is i don't know let's say it's let's say
it's small let's let's try to get a
respectable number
let's say this is one let's say that
they're one millimeter apart
one millimeter but we want everything in
kind of our standard units so that all
the units work out so let's convert to
meters so that equals
1 times 10 to the minus 3
meters so they're pretty close apart and
let's figure out the
well let's let's do let's do the the
force on wire 1 due to current two just
so so that we can see that this is also
repelled so let's say that where the the
length in question l1
is equal to i don't know let's make it a
long a long wire
10 meters
all right so how do we do this so first
let's figure out the magnitude of the
magnetic field created by i2 so the
magnitude of the magnetic field created
by i2
i drew this hand too big took up too
much space so the magnetic field
created by current two
worried about the magnitude of it
that is equal we saw it before and we're
assuming that these are you know it's an
error so we can use the permeability
of a vacuum so it's equal to that
constant the permeability of a vacuum
times
i2
it's just a magnitude
and remember we figure out the direction
by wrapping our hand around it we'll do
that in a second divided by 2 pi times
the radius so 2
pi
radius so let's see so let me just we
could just put it in the so the
magnitude
of the magnetic field
is equal to
well we'll just keep that that
i2
i said is 3 amperes times 3 amperes
divided by 2 pi
times
times 1 times 10 to the minus 3.
and let's see and that answer will be in
tesla's
all right there we already have the
permeability of a vacuum there so let's
write that down permeability of a vacuum
times
divided by
second
pi
times
e
minus
3. and i get the answer will be in
tesla's 6e minus 4 teslas
so the magnitude of the magnetic field
there
created by current 2 is equal to 6 times
10 to the minus 4
teslas now what's the direction of that
magnetic field so here we use our wrap
around rule take your right hand wrap it
around the wire in the direction of the
current and then you'll get the shape of
the magnetic field so if i take my right
hand my thumb goes in the shape of the
current my hand is going to look
something like this and my knuckles the
fingers are going to come out on that
end right so the magnetic field
caused by current 2 is going to look
something like that
so on this side of the wire where it
intersects with the plane it'll be
popping out
and on this side it'll be
popping in
right
so on this side it'll be popping in
fair enough so now we can figure out
what the net force on this first wire is
let me let me erase some of this just so
i have some
free space
let's see we already know
we already know we already use the three
amperes we already used all of that
we already used all of that in fact we
just need to know that this magnetic
field that's popping out of the page we
just need to know its magnitude
we actually could even get rid of this
whole drawing because now we just know
that this has created a magnetic field
and now we just worry about the magnetic
field in this wire but anyway i'll leave
it there just so we remember what the
whole problem was
so what's the net force on this on wire
one so the net force on y or one
so we could say caused by wire two on
wire one is equal to the current in wire
one so that's two amperes
times
the vector well this is l1
l1 i'll write l1 right now
cross the magnetic field
across the magnetic field and really we
just worry about the magnitude because
the direction we can figure out with the
right well let's figure out the
direction first of all so l1 is going
upwards so that's the direction of our
index finger b is going into the page
right this is b2 that's the magnetic
field created by this wire so it's going
into the page so if we use the right
hand rule
what happens my index finger is going in
the direction of the current in
direction of i1 my middle finger is
pointed downward so you can't see it's
pointing into the page of my other two
fingers do what they need to do and so
my thumb will point in the direction of
the net force right that's the top of my
hand
so the net force is in that direction
right
so we don't have to worry about the
vectors too much anymore because we know
the end direction of the net force so
what's the magnitude
so the magnitude of the force
is equal to the current
2 amperes
times the magnitude of the
times the magnitude of the distance
times 10 meters
times the magnitude of the magnetic
field that's 6 times 10 to the minus 4
teslas and then when you take the cross
product you take the sine of the theta
between these two vectors right but
they're perpendicular the magnetic field
is
going into the page while the direction
vector of the wire the length of the
wire is going along the page so they are
perpendicular so the sine of theta just
comes out to be one so you can just so
when things are perpendicular don't have
to worry about that sine theta you can
almost just multiply the terms and then
use your right hand rule for the
direction so anyway this gives us
20 times 6 120 times 10 to the minus 4
that's the same thing as what 1.2 times
to the minus 2.
so the magnitude of the force
is one point two force from current two
on wire one
the magnitude is one point two times ten
to the minus two newtons because we used
all the right units and the direction is
outward and so if we knew the mass
of this
we would you know you just divide the
force by the mass you would know how
fast it's accelerating at that moment
outwards of course as it gets further
and further away the the magnetic field
is going to get weaker so the net force
is going to get weaker so it'll start
accelerating at a slower and slower
speed sorry at a slower and slower rate
but of course you're still accelerating
so you are going to continue to
move away faster and faster anyway all
out of time see you in the next video